The Queen biopic Bohemian Rhapsody is loaded
with moments, songs and details that many
fans will doubtless love, but did you catch
them all?
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'm revealing six crazy
little details, secrets and easter eggs you
might have missed in the movie.
Keep watching to the end to find out which
Queen band member had a hidden cameo in the
film.
And subscribe and leave a comment about the
movie for a chance to win some awesome Bohemian
Rhapsody merch.
You can spot the inspiration behind the cover
art for Queen's second album in the opening
scene of the movie when Freddie walks past
an iconic portrait of Marlene Dietrich from
her 1932 Oscar-winning movie Shanghai Express.
The renowned photographer Mick Rock had been
hired by Queen to come up with a striking
image for their second album "Queen II".
After Rock discovered a picture of Dietrich
with her arms crossed and lit from above with
a top light, he proposed the look for the
band's album cover.
They agreed and Freddie even imitated Dietrich's
arms crossed and fingers spread pose.
And a shot of the band lit in a similar way
appears as the opening of their Bohemian Rhapsody
music video.
After Freddie tells Paul Prenter to organize
a spectacular party at his home, the movie
gives us a glimpse at some of the singer's
legendary events.
And when they designed the set for the big
party scene, the filmmakers deliberately included
"references to Freddie's interests and Queen's
history".
In fact, there's a moment where Freddie passes
by two scantily-clad women riding a couple
of stationary bikes.
That's an easter egg to Queen's "Bicycle Race"
single, which was released as a double A-side
with "Fat Bottomed Girls".
The music video for "Bicycle Race" is famous
for being filmed with many nude models all
racing around on bicycles at Wimbledon Stadium.
Mike Myers makes a fun cameo in the movie
as fictional EMI executive Ray Foster who
refuses to release "Bohemian Rhapsody" because
it's too long and radio stations won't play
it.
Among Foster's many complaints about the song
is a little inside joke.
He tells Queen that "Bohemian Rhapsody" will
never be the kind of song that teenagers will
crank up the volume in their car and start
head banging to.
Which is funny because, of course, that's
exactly what Mike Myers did back in 1992 in
the movie Wayne's World when he and his friends
played Bohemian Rhapsody in their car and
started head-banging along to the
Fun fact: for Wayne's World, Mike Myers actually
had to fight the studio to get Bohemian Rhapsody
in the film as the producers originally wanted
Guns 'N' Roses instead as they were very popular
when the movie was being made.
After Wayne's World was released though, that
memorable moment brought Queen back into the
spotlight in the US and when Bohemian Rhapsody
was re-released, the song reached No. 2 on
the Billboard Hot 100.
The Live Aid performance is one of the highlights
of Bohemian Rhapsody.
There were, of course, many famous bands on
stage that day, and if you look very carefully
in the scene at the start of the film as Freddie
is going on stage, just coming off stage is
a young Bono, the lead singer for U2, plus
you can spot his three U2 bandmates following
behind him.
It's a fun nod because at the time Queen and
U2's performances were considered by many
to be the best of the day.
And by the way, look carefully in the crowd
shots as there's also a banner which reads
"We Love U2".
Although this moment in the film implies U2
played Live Aid right before Queen, in reality
it was Dire Straits who were on stage [just]
before Freddie and co.
However, just before we see that scene again
at the end of the film, I think you can hear
Dire Straits' music playing in the background
over various shots including Freddie and his
bandmates waiting in their trailer.
By the way, if you'd like to find out about
some bigger changes the movie made to Queen's
real-life story, you can watch my other video
which I'll link at the end and in the video
description.
While original Queen bandmates Brian May and
Roger Taylor were involved in Bohemian Rhapsody
behind the scenes as producers, they didn't
make on-screen cameo unless they were heavily
disguised as Mike Myers was.
However, who did appear was Queen's new lead
vocalist Adam Lambert.
The former American Idol star, who has collaborated
with Queen for over six years, made a cameo
as a trucker.
Lambert appears in the scene where Freddie
is on tour in the US and talking on the phone
to Mary who's back home in England.
Lambert's trucker then catches Freddie's eye
before going into the men's public restroom.
Now, did you spot any other interesting details
or Queen easter eggs in Bohemian Rhapsody?
And what was your favourite song in the movie?
Let me know in the comments below and remember
to subscribe for a chance to win one of these
cool Bohemian Rhapsody merch packs.
Tap left to learn about the seven scenes and
songs deleted from the movie or tap right
to learn about the biggest changes Bohemian
Rhapsody made to the real story of Queen.
Let me know if you enjoyed this and a thumbs-up
or a share is always appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!